on va rappeler que vous êtes président
fondateur de la ligue de défense noire
africaine et gucci vous ça forcément ça
vous a choqué si des riches sidéré
vraiment réussi d'airé vous avez eu de
nombreux appels de nombreux témoignages
de personnes qui vous ont dit c'est
c'est compliqué pour nous de devoir sa
de 2,2 d'être confronté à ça oui c'est
tous les jours au quotidien parce que tu
étais à des personnes qui ne sont pas au
courant mais les afrodescendants les
personnes
citoyens citoyennes de la communauté
noire en france sont victimes de de
négrophobie tous les jours et la
négrophobie tu es le blackface
contribuent à nourrir alimenter tout ce
que nous subissons
donc ça nous sidère tous les jours de
voir de telles pratiques en france ça
vous peine
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre quête
quand vous voyez ça quand il ya des gens
qui vous disent on en a marre d'être
présenté comme ça qu'est ce qu'est ce
que ce qu'est ce qui se passe ce qui se
passe c'est que on ne comprend pas
contrairement aux autres pays en europe
dans la france aussi fait partie de
l'onu l'onu condamne le blackface et
qu'en france on arrive encore à discuter
de telles pratiques
en fait il y a des choses sur lesquelles
on ne discute pas mais quand ça concerne
les afrodescendants la communauté noire
on arrive toujours à vouloir trouver une
excuse pour banaliser la souffrance des
noirs pourtant la mémoire est très
importante et la souffrance des noirs il
faut sur les temps que ça compte aussi
autant que la souffrance des juifs des
arméniens d algérie au fait ça doit les
gours les huits goût accepté en a parlé
hier faut comprendre que nous ça nous
choque de voir ce monsieur se plaindre
le corps en noir pour représenter ou
voilà ça ça ne choque alors il y en a
qui comprennent pas vous battre à
castéra mans est normal je comprends
très bien ce que vous avez expliqué mais
dans le cas précis de gérard darmon qui
poste
cette photo parce qu'il va faire un film
et voilà je pense que je vois pas je
pense que c'est pas du tout dans un but
néfastes pas du tout savons simplement
certain maintenant vous avez raison sur
le tour discours mais il ya ceux qui
font un bac faith sur les tours et non
pour se moquer de la communauté noire ça
c'est un fait qui doit qu'il faut
condamner dans le cas de darmon je pense
qu'il n'a pas fait a mal et je pense que
dans son cas précis c'est parce que
c'est un acteur et que voilà
othello il trouve que auto et noir et
qui va faire un personnage dans dans
marleau donc je pense sincèrement que
parfois et c'est un peu le premier
combat en ce moment sur plein de sujets
c'est que le code le combat est
évidemment nomme vous avez raison sur
tout mais on peut pas toujours il faut
ça va être femme
il me semble parfois il faut savoir
distinguer ce qui est vraiment une
agression et ce qui pour le coup n'a
rien à voir avec une agression parce que
parfois à aller à faire trop de combats
je pense que ça va à l'encontre de votre
combat voilà